like Flanagan's adaptation of Stephen
King's novel features a strong cast of
recognizable actors both major stars and
supporting players we've definitely seen
before things are about to get eerie as
we figure out why the cast of dr. sleep
looks so familiar the leader of the true
not Colts ghost by Rosa Hatt and she
looks to be a formidable antagonist for
Danny Torrance in the film Rosa's played
by Rebecca Ferguson he started acting in
a Swedish soap opera but she's had
plenty of stateside success over the
last decade the Swedish actress is
probably best known for playing Elsa
Foust and a newer Mission Impossible
films
she's also no stranger to horror roles
as she appeared in life is Miranda North
and the Snowman as Catrin Bratz on top
of all that Ferguson has appeared in
movies ranging from the greatest showman
and the kitty would be king two men in
black international and Florence Foster
Jenkins in other words Ferguson is an
in-demand actress talented formidable
and the perfect pet for such a
terrifying Stephen King character one of
Danny's allies against the true not as
Billy Freeman a man who helps I hero
cope with his alcoholism and fight
against his inner demons he takes on a
similar role to dick hallorann from The
Shining serving as an older mentor
striving to help Danny with a stroma in
dr. sleep a veteran actor cliff Curtis
portrays Billy Freeman Curtis got his
big break in 1999 Street Kings but he
played Ameer Abdullah since then he's
appeared in several movies and shows
where he's played roles like Pablo
Escobar and blue smiley in training day
and Travis and fear the walking dead one
of the most frightening members of the
Troon artist named crow daddy he's Rosa
hats lover and a sadistic terrifying
individual dr. sleep features an
inspired bit of casting for Crow daddy
as he's played by Sam McLennan a man who
lends plenty of gravitas to every role
he takes
McClellan has been acting professionally
for more than 30 years appearing in
several television shows in the 90s as
well as providing voice work for several
animated films over the years he started
appearing in larger roles playing
characters like handsy and the Fargo
television series and the professor in
bone tomahawk probably his most
recognizable role is that of a cat
cheetah the leader of the ghost nation
tribe on HBO's Westworld cookie uru kuia
we are key hinge
oh yeah one of Danny's allies and close
friends in dr. sleep dr. John knows more
about Donnie them pretty much anyone
he's aware that Danny possesses an
extraordinary ability and he also knows
that Danny isn't the only one with the
shine in the film dr. John is played by
Bruce Greenwood and Greenwood is no
stranger to playing roles that require a
commanding on-screen presence Greenwood
has played roles like John F Kennedy in
13 days the President of the United
States in Kingsman the Golden Circle and
Christopher Pike and the more recent
Star Trek films
he's also no stranger to Stephen King
gay levitations directed by Mike
Flanagan since he played Gerald and
Gerald's game and he did what you always
do when he gets too much you ran in here
some of the true nots have gained
psychic powers through their exposure to
the shine and snake bite Andy is one of
the most vicious and formidable psychics
imaginable and he has the power to make
people fall into a deep sleep
with just a verbal suggestion snake bite
Andy is played by emily alyn lind in dr.
sleep and that ding is in her blood her
mother is Barbara Allen Woods so Lynn's
got started acting at a very young age
she appeared a Shirley Temple in j.edgar
and in several television series before
the age of 10 more recently Lind
appeared as Sophie Foster in replicas
Ariel on the CBS series code black and
young Amanda Clarke on the ABC series
revenge another member of the true north
grandpa Flicka kicks off the events of
dr. sleep in a lot of ways since the
group strives to be immortal by stealing
the shine from children watching a
member of their cult grow older
frightens and infuriates the other
members of the group pastor who portrays
grandpa Fleck you've definitely seen
actor carel struycken in plenty of roles
Stryker has played monsters and other
characters and many things including the
giant and Twin Peaks mr. Harmon Star
Trek The Next Generation the moonlight
man in Gerald's game and the bold are
Kelly in from men in black one of his
most memorable roles was as large in the
Addams Family and Addams Family Values
but no matter the project the seven-foot
tall Dutchman always makes an impression
when he strides onto the screen
[Music]
it is happening okay
without getting too heavy into spoiler
territory the character of Lucy plays a
small but important role than dr. sleep
as such the filmmakers needed to cast a
confident actress to take on the part
and they found one in joseline Donahue
Donahue has made a pretty good name for
herself by taking on roles that seemed
thankless on paper and making them
memorable her horror credentials are
certainly there she played the young
version of Lorraine in insidious chapter
two and she won the best actress award
at la scream fest in 2009 for the lead
role in the indie darling the house of
the devil silence areas perhaps the most
frightening member of the true not to do
to her impressive psyche a gift Harry
can essentially make people not realize
she's there as long as I don't see her
moving she's basically invisible silence
Sarah is portrayed by Katharine Parker
who certainly possesses the right
combination of charisma and threat to
play the character early in her career
Parker found a good deal of acclaim in
the role of Callie in absentia which led
to memorable roles on shows like halting
catch fire and masters of sex recently
horror fans saw her as poppy Hill the
creepy flapper woman on Netflix is the
haunting of Hill House which was also
directed by Mike Flanagan in Stephen
King's novel the character of Dini plays
a big part in getting Danny to the town
where most of dr. sleeps action takes
place it's a small but important role
but Chelsea told me just a perfect
actress to cast in such a pivotal role
the other projects that Tallmadge is
known for generally gave her small
scenes to play with and she managed to
make them memorable Tallmadge appeared
on the series holton catch fire playing
Vera in six episodes of the show she
also had a recurring role on the Billy
Ray Cyrus sitcom still the king as Mabel
the role you're most likely to recognize
her from it's stranger things
she played Carol one of the students who
attend the pool party where Bob
disappears and she later cheers on her
boyfriend Tommy and Steve Harrington
when they break Jonathan Baez camera
dude
yeah this isn't creepy at all Berry is a
member of the true nuts and he's a
reminder to the group of why it's so
important that they continue to feed off
the shine of others he's played and dug
to sleep by Robert Longstreet's who film
fans have assured least seen in
something over the years long streets
are speeding around 80 rolls in as many
years as an actor but he's only started
to garner mainstream attention recently
he played Anderson in Boots Reilly's
bizarre satire sorry to bother you and
he played professor James and Aquaman he
also has credits in take shelter the old
man and the gun and Mohawk plus horror
hounds will recognize him as mr. Dudley
the kindly caretaker harboring a dark
secret in the haunting of Hill House if
you're familiar with the movie version
of The Shining then you might be
surprised to see dick hallorann as a
character and dr. sleep in the movie
Halloran doesn't survive his experience
at the Overlook Hotel
however he survives in the book and
tolerance still has a role to play in
Danny's life when the sequel rolls
around coulombe Lee has been cast in the
role that Scatman Crothers played in the
original Kubrick film lovey has had a
huge variety of roles over his career
including several voice acting
performances in cartoons and video games
as far as roles where he's actually
showed up on camera lumpley is probably
best known for playing Marcus Dixon on
the show alias he's played mark brassia
in the film Men of Honor and he also
features in a recurring role on the
Supergirl series another member of the
true North's apron annie has a very
small role in dr. sleep that said you'll
probably be stuffing your fingers and
racking your brain when you see the
actress who plays her Selena undos up on
the screen you've definitely seen her in
at least one thing and it's a place
you've seen several of the other actors
in dr. sleep
Selena on two toes in the haunting of
Hill House Julia appeared in one episode
the twin thing as a worker at the rehab
facility in fact on do seems to almost
exclusively play doctors and detectives
you may also have seen on dews and small
roles in movies like venom as The Bistro
manager or a Madea family funeral as the
doctor undos was supposed to have a
fairly meaty role in the DC series Swamp
Thing as Caroline Woodruff a bad show's
swept cancellation put a stop to that
role dr. sleep would hardly be the story
of Danny's coping with his childhood
trauma if his mother wasn't a part of
things in the shining Shelley Duvall
played Wendy Torrance with wide-eyed
panic and Dalek says so is taking on the
role in dr. sleep and so
visually hails from Saudi Arabia and
she's only been acting professionally
since 2008 she hasn't really had a big
breakout role at this point let's
hopefully dr. sleep will put her on the
path to bigger and better things
what Esso does have is a lot of horror
experience she's appeared in indie
horror films like sorry eyes the
neighbor dark intentions and Midnighters
she also appeared in the drone which is
about a drone that gained sentience and
goes on a killing spree the true not in
dr. sleeper mostly preys on children so
there are several roles that Jacob
Tremblay could be taking on considering
Tremblay is impressive resume and prior
experience working with director Mike
Flanagan it seems likely he's taking on
a substantial role in the film our money
is on him playing young Danny Torrance
regardless of what role Tremblay plays
we know he's in the film and you've
probably seen something else he's been
in he's actually done quite a bit of
voice work but one of his biggest roles
was alongside pre lasted in the
critically acclaimed film room
considering his impressive performance
in room it's hard to imagine Tremblay
would play just some random kid in
doctor sleep Tremblay has some other
impressive credentials as well he was
Cody and before I wake a prior
collaboration with dr. sleep director
Mike Flanagan and played Rory McKenna in
the predator chances are good that you
don't need a reminder about you and
McGregor the actor who plays a grown-up
Danny Torrance in dr. sleep before the
actors in the film he's about the only
household name if you somehow once able
to put a film to his face though here's
what you've seen him in McGregor showed
promise early on stealing this show into
impressive indie films shallow grave and
Trainspotting however it was his casting
as young obi-wan Kenobi in the Star Wars
prequels has shot McGregor to
superstardom
he also played Edie Bloom in big fish
Philip Morris and I love you Philip
Morris Christian a Moulin Rouge and the
title character in Christopher Robin in
other words that dude is incredibly
talented and an impressive anchor for
the cast's of dr. sleep check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]